مرحبا بكم مشاهدينا نتابع هذه التغطيه
لتطورات الاحداث والغارات الاسرائيليه
التي بدات على مواقع في قطاع غزه اضافه
الى حاله الحذر التي تسود الحدود
اللبنانيه الاسرائيليه اثراء اطلاق
الصواريخ بعد ظهر اليوم على
شمال اسرائيل نبدا من الان نبدا من راس
الناقوره على الحدود الاسرائيليه
اللبنانيه مع مراسل الجزيره الياس كرام
الذي يرصد المشهد هناك خصوصا في ضوء بدء
الغارات الاسرائيليه على مواقع في قطاع
غزه الياس
نعم بالفعل ونحن نشير هنا الى البيان
الاخير الذي صدر عن الجيش الاسرائيلي قبل
قليل والذي قال فيه بان الغارات الجويه
التي شنها الجيش الاسرائيلي في قطاع غزه
استهدفت نفقين ارهابيين بحسب تعبير البيان
وموقعين لتصنيع وسائل قتاليه تابعه لحركه
هذا هو حسن البيان الرسمي للجيش
الاسرائيلي بعد هذه الموجه الاولى من
الضربات التي وجهتها اسرائيل
لقطاع غزه هذا العدوان الجديد على القطاع
ونشير في المقابل الى ان ذوي الصافات
صافرات الانذار كان مسموعا في العديد من
البلدات الاسرائيليه المتاخمه لحدود قطاع
غزه بعضها وصل حتى الى المنطقه الجنوبيه
لعسقلان منطقه تيفا عصرا والمنطقه
الصناعيه في جنوب اي مدينه عسقلان بطبيعه
الحال حسن كما هو معروف من
موجات مواجهه سابقه ما بين المقاومه
الفلسطينيه واسرائيل هنالك اختبار للردات
الفعل الان اسرائيل قامت بهجومها الاول
وما من شك كما يبدو انه ستكون هنالك كما
يبدو موجات وضربات اخرى في قادم الساعات
وكذلك هو رد الفعل الفلسطيني هو متدرج
ومتدحرج بمعنى ان الان الضربات التي
تسددها المقاومه الفلسطينيه هي تتركز على
البلدات الاسرائيليه المتاخمه للحدود وهي
البلدات الواقعه على بعد كيلومترات فقط من
السياج الامني لكن فيما اذا قامت اسرائيل
بتصعيد هجماتها وعدوانها على قطاع غزه فان
ايضا المقاومه الفلسطينيه قادره على تعميق
استهدافاتها وتوسيع دائره الاستهدافات
للمدن الاسرائيليه بمعنى انها قد تدخل على
خط هذه المواجهه مدن كمدينه بئر السبع وهي
اكبر المدن الاسرائيليه في قلب صحراء
النقب وقد تتجه ايضا شمالا لتضرب
بلدات ومواقع عسكريه واستراتيجيه تقع الى
الجنوب من مدينه تل ابيب وضواحيها
الجنوبيه لتصل بعد ذلك الى المناطق
المتاخمه لمطار بن غوريون الدولي لتعطله
كما حدث في مرات سابقه نشير هنا حسن الى
ان المقاومه الفلسطينيه في اخر مواجهه لها
مع الجيش الاسرائيلي في عام 2021 ونقصدنا
تحديدا حركه حماس كانت اظهرت قدره كبيره
في تطوير الاسلحه وتطوير الصواريخ حيث
انها اطلقت صاروخا وصل مداهه الى نحو 200
كم عندما وجهت احد الصواريخ باتجاه
المنطقه الجنوبيه لاسرائيل واستهدفت فيه
مطار رامون المدني الذي يقع على بعد
30 كيلومترا الى الشمال من مدينه ايلات
على البحر الاحمر وهذه القدرات الصاروخيه
ما من شك في انها تطورت والجيش الاسرائيلي
يعرف ذلك وبالتالي الان الرد الفعل من
جانب المقاومه الفلسطينيه يعتمد بطبيعه
الحال على عمق الهجوم الذي تشنه اسرائيل
والعدوان الذي تشنه على قطاع غزه في هذه
الساعات